hello and welcome everyone to the
session on hyper permit optimization for
the inpatient great to see so many
people show up um that's it's pretty
cool um yeah my name is Martin Vista I'm
working at AWS and yeah well maybe the
first parts will be a bit boring so stay
with me here
um so yeah machine learning pretty much
is being used Now everywhere for example
you would use it for image detection
um in this particular example let's say
you have an image or just a video where
you would like to to detect objects in
this case the car it could be also
people on the street bikes and so on
another popular application is basically
on tax data like with gbt this whole
field of natural language processing
become very visible in the public so in
this particular case this this would be
entity recognition and some medical
records where you would identify
um like the patient's name gender age
um medical dosages and so on
other cases of course are recommended
systems and ranking and General this
this is probably a big field of for
example
um at Amazon apparently we also do that
but you also have it like in video
streaming platforms or so on way the the
system would just recommend you tools
items you would be interested in based
on your history like what things you've
watched what things you've clicked on
um
and finally also pretty cool feature
code completion something we already
have in our Ides for a long time but
this one is a machine learning driven
one where basically based on your
context it would recommend your entire
function theme and so this little
example is
throwing pretty much what these things
can do so here you would just write a
comment describing what the function is
doing and now you start writing your
python function and you get Auto
completion for the entire logic so they
are pretty cool things you can do with
machine learning so what do we need to
do machine learning so I guess the most
common ingredients are the data set
obviously then we have a model that has
typically parameters and you would need
to estimate these parameters
and you estimate these parameters
typically within a training algorithm
and these components are oftentimes like
the core components that's what people
think about what's oftentimes overlooked
or maybe
doesn't get that much attention because
it's a little bit annoying to figure
that out correctly is how to find the
configuration for the training algorithm
because that's typically also something
you need to set the training algorithm
is just an algorithm right which gets
other input than just a data set in the
model and we will focus on this letter
part which is maybe not super exciting
but that's something we need to struggle
with in practice a lot so what is this
thing and these things are basically the
hyper parameters so we will talk about
hyper parameter optimization and Hyper
parameters are basically omnipresent in
machine learning whatever algorithm you
use you certainly have one or more of
them right depending on how complex that
is
you could consider hyper parameters also
many other things that are kind of
related for example just a question of
algorithm selection like do I use a
neural network for my data do I use a
random for us to support Vector machine
or whatnot that's kind of a decision
need to make
there would be more classical hyper
parameters let's say like for example
for your optimization of your neural
network you would need to set the
learning rate the batch size the number
of epochs if you want to go a step
further like for the neural network that
you want to use you would also need to
Define its architecture right so you
would need to decide how deep is it how
wide is it and going further you might
even choose what are the layers I'm
using do I use the convolutional layer
here do I use max pooling and then of
course that's the question how do I
connect them all right this entire
wiring so this could be very complex and
this is typically a manual task
so this was mostly about neural networks
now but obviously other learning
algorithms have this as well like for
tabular data these tree based methods
like random forests or HC boosts are
very popular and here you would need to
set the number of trees the depth of the
tree splitting Criterion and so on
and finally most often these cyber
parameters are also related to model
complexity so you might have some
regularization constant
and so how do I know whether a hyper
parameter configuration is not a good
one what we would need to do that is
just try it and trying it means I need
to train with it and that's the big
problem because training is expensive
so just give you to give you an example
and we will use this as a running
example to just show you what the impact
of these different algorithms are let's
say we have a resnet 18 model that's a
conversion convolutional neural network
it's an older one it's smaller one
cheaper to train and let's say we would
just want to train that on imagenet
imagenet is a popular image
classification data set with 1000
classes relatively large
now let's say we just want to use a
single GPU a V100 that currently costs
around three dollars when we if when we
use this um ec2 instance and so a single
Epoch meaning a single Passover data set
takes us 16 minutes
so now let's say we want to optimize the
hyper parameters learning rate way Decay
momentum and Dropout and we would do a
grid search meaning for each of these
type of parameters we use four
configurations and let's say for the way
Decay we just use two this is saying we
want to use maybe not the ytk but maybe
the momentum we say we want to use or we
don't want to use it and then if we take
the cross product of all these
operations that that will give us
basically the grid we want to optimize
for we end up having 128 configurations
if we would train all of them we won't
basically spend 128 GPU days on this and
we would pay 9 000
um dollars and the big problem here is
that the money or time you invest for
hyper parameter optimization is
something you do up front right this
money is gone and you don't know whether
it was worth it right we do have a
parameter optimization for the only
reason to improve performance so that in
our task we would you know increase
Revenue in some sense and so we get that
money back but now we spend it already
up front and we have no guarantee
whether getting it half a percent
accuracy higher would actually mean that
in our application we would see that you
know people are spending more money or
something on our platform right and
that's if you do this in practice you
know better model doesn't really mean it
makes more money
um
so yeah that's a problem right and this
is the entire premise in this talk that
small improvements do not necessarily
will get at gains
um in practice so we are fine with
sacrificing a little bit of accuracy but
spending a lot of
um time and money here and so we will
look into some approximate methods that
will make it yeah 20 to 50 times
faster
and we in some cases we might lose
performance but we are totally fine with
that
okay so what will be the lessons that I
hope you will all um learn in this
session so first of all we will talk a
little bit about come and have a permit
optimization methods and how they work
um
we answer the question what are the
advantages shortcomings and when to use
which
um then of course that's why I hope you
are here how can I tune the Cyber
parameters extremely fast
and while these are the mostly very
theoretically I also want to give you
some pointers how to do them in practice
so how we can use some open source
libraries to do it you know by yourself
without re-implementing the algorithms I
will discuss
okay so this basically the outline so we
start with the basics
um you might have seen some of them
maybe you don't have so I want to lay
here the foundation for the entire talk
so everyone is
on the same page and then we talk about
extremely fast cyber parameter
optimization
um then the third one is I think
particularly interesting here we have
the scenario that many people face in
practice that you basically have some
system where you over time basically
gather more data and would retune
regularly right
so and we are finally some conclusions
um first I want to define the problem
and the notation
um I guess that's the most complicated
slide in the entire talks so bear with
me here
um
so we will have some training algorithm
right a data set and what we want to do
is we want to get a model which
generalizes well meaning it would
perform good on
the the data we will see over time and
then that our customers will generate
for example
so the entire task in hyper parameter
optimization is just to find the hyper
parameter configuration X in our search
Space calligraphic X which is Chiefs
this goal and if we now Define
um basically the generalization score
of a model that's trained on D with the
configuration X as f of x we will call
this function f also the response
function then the problem itself like
mathematically looks rather simple so we
want to maximize our generalization
score with respect to the hybrid
parameters
keep in mind evaluating F that's an
expensive function what we would need to
do to evaluate is train our model on the
data with configuration X and evaluate
it on some holder data sets right so
this is not differentiable
um
great
um so I mentioned earlier that one could
use grid search
um I will tell you now why you should
never do that
um so that was bad advice but I think
this is oftentimes used in practice the
reason why we don't want to use it so
maybe as a background grid search is
this entire thing where you pick for
each hyper parameter a few settings and
then you take the cross product so you
get this grid of configurations that you
want to try
so the problem is most algorithms have
different type of hyper parameters some
are super sensitive
and some which aren't and if we look on
the response function on the left side
um
well I guess that's completely useless
uh
do you see the point at all nah
okay anyway so if you check the plot on
the left side this is basically a 3D
plot of some response function that has
two hyper parameters
one being sensitive
so you see if we move our configuration
at that direction the response function
changes quite a bit and the other one
being insensitive so it doesn't change a
lot so what would that mean in Grid
search these hyper parameters are always
access aligned basically meaning that if
you know a check for one sensitive
parameter and different settings for the
insensitive parameter basically the
performance doesn't change at all so we
basically waste time in a grid search
and it's smarter and basically as
complicated to implement solution to
this problem is use a random search so
we just randomly sample configurations
we don't have that problem we
effectively are testing more
configurations
um okay well let's come to Bayesian
optimization so grid search and random
search is such a relatively naive so
they do not adapt over time to what
they've seen right you tested some
configurations now you wouldn't want to
pick the next one and you would not even
consider what you already know about the
response function Basin optimization
basically tackles this by using two
components one is the surrogate model
that's some probabilistic model that
basically tries to approximate the
response function based on the the
observations we have and then there's
the acquisition function which would
basically score each hyper parameter so
it would give each hyper parameter a
score based on the surrogate models
believe on how well that is doing as
well as its uncertainty
um so that might sound a bit complex
let's let's get a bit more visual here
so I think it's easier to understand
um so let's say this orange line that's
the response function we want to
maximize so what we did know is we have
already three hyper parameters we
optimize four here
um so three different configurations
there's only one hyper parameter in this
case
um so we get these circles as
observations so what we do is we fit our
surrogate model which is basically it's
predicting as a mean the solid black
line and it gives us uncertainty
estimates which are the dashed
um
Gray Line and as you see in areas where
we have data the uncertainty is low
where we don't have data inside right
that what we assume
and then we can compute the acquisition
function the acquisition function
basically takes as a like it's a
trade-off between exploration and
exploitation considering the mean
prediction and uncertainty
and basically giving us a score for each
hyper parameter so what you would do is
you maximize that acquisition function
and at the maximum the hyper parameter
is the one that we would try next
and then we would update our surrogate
model we would maximize our acquisition
function again and would keep going and
in that way our surrogate model would be
better at approximating this response
function but we would also find better
better hyper parameters
okay
um so what we've seen so far as random
search based on optimization and the
problem with these are is that they are
very expensive because
both of them require you for each
configuration to train until completion
and that's yeah well taking some time
um
however these are great Solutions if
compute time is no concern for you so if
that's no limitation just go for this
and you can leave the room I guess if
that's a concern for you the next part
will be a bit more interesting so what
we will look into is approximate station
of
these these optimizations and so the
entire idea will be that instead of
training until completion we use some
other ways that approximate basically
how well a training run would do so we
would save you some time but since it's
an approximation it won't do as well
and this is this entire field of
multi-fidelity optimization
so here the idea is we would either
train on fewer data or we would train
for fewer epochs meaning fewer passes
over the entire data and if we do that
this would not entirely match what you
would get if you train on the full data
or for full um epochs but the score we
observed here that is a proxy for the
True Performance so we could use this
cheaper information to basically tune
our hyper parameters
so the advantage here is if we compare
to something like random search if we
say we we fix the number of
configurations or let's say 100
if you do it with some multi-fidelity
optimization technique you would spend
less compute time
if you fix the search budget in contrary
what that means is you could try in the
same time way more configurations
so if time constraint is really
you know
um hard then this will typically find
better solution even though it's an
approximation
as I mentioned earlier if compute
constraints are no problem this is just
an approximation
um so in that case it will not work as
well
um
so and I guess the figure there below
shows you kind of the idea of this
method so what it will do is it starts
training them so you see here learning
curves and some runs are basically
stopped early if they don't look
promising in the beginning
um so yeah let's let's check the first
one this will be basically the
foundation for all the algorithms we
discussed this is successive halving and
it's a relatively simple algorithm so
the idea is that you provide some
minimum budget you want to spend on a
configuration use
um also the Define a maximum budget you
want to spend and what you would do is
you sample like and random search
configurations at random you train them
with the minimum budget
check for the minimum budget however
they do and then kick out fifty percent
of the candidates that are doing worst
then you double the budget
train them
do the same thing again kick them out
double them
and of course this whole thing of
doubling halfening that's just one way
of doing it you can also replace this
Factor two by some ETA to make it a
little bit more General
so visually let's assume we have eight
configurations sampled completely and
random we train them for the lowest
budget which is one in this case we
evaluate them rank them so one being the
best performing one eight being the
worst performing one and our successive
halfing is doing we kick out the 50
which do the worst now we doubled the
budget
train them until to the budget two and
just keep doing the same kick out half
of them double the budget kick out half
of them without the budget and what we
would see here is in random search we
would have trained them all until
completion right so I guess very clear
why we are saving time here
um
okay hyperband is a variation of
successive Farthing um it basically is
an answer to the question how do I know
how to set my minimum budget it's a
relatively simple approach here what
type of band basically proposes to do is
that instead of running success evolving
for one minimum budget it would just run
it in parallel for multiple different
settings of the minimum budget one of
them being even the maximum budget so
one of these brackets or parallel runs
of successive halfing is equivalent to
random search that would give you the
same asymptotic guarantees as random
search so there's some nice thing uh
like on the theoretical part of this
algorithm
okay let's come back to our computation
so how far did we come so far um so the
the example I gave you earlier that's
basically an example for random search
um now we look into how much we would
spend with successive halfing the number
of configurations we try is exactly the
same
but since this algorithm is a little bit
smart about when to stop configurations
we are bringing down the number of
epochs by around the factor of 20 so
that's also why it's much cheaper right
and now you can ask yourself whether
400 dollars is better than 9k if you
trade off a little bit in a curse
um okay great so this is like the
foundation or most of you might have
seen there before so now we're looking
into some algorithm that we've developed
so the first one being Pasha
um
as mentioned earlier hyperband already
alleviates the problem of setting the
minimum budget Pasha is also taking care
of the maximum budget and similar to the
minimum budget we have here two problems
if yeah B is basically too small the
solution we find is not a good one if
it's too large we we simply waste
compute and what Pasha does it basically
automatically chooses to be for you and
in that way
um will save you some budget
um
and the entire idea here is that
you would like to train configurations
as long as they have not converged as
soon as you realize configurations have
converged meaning their ranking doesn't
change anymore that's when we want to
stop increasing the budget
okay back to the visualization
um same thing eight configurations we
train them rank them kick out half of
them and whenever we go to the next
budget and evaluate them we would need
to check whether the ranking has changed
compared to the previous run if that's
not the case we would stop and in this
simple example we already reached this
this time and yeah we stop so this is
where we save the time here this however
is a little bit naive so this is more
the motivation behind it because in
practice this ranking will never be
stable simply to some inherent noise in
the training process so there will be
always a little bit differences in the
ranking
um so what we propose to do is use some
kind of software ranking so instead of
ranking the configurations we rank sets
and each set basically contains um a
configuration or all the configurations
that are by at most in epsilon different
and if these rank assignments no longer
change that's the point of time where we
stop training now we've added this
additional hyper hyper parameter Epsilon
but this is something that Pasha would
also set automatically in a data driven
Way by basically setting it to the 19th
percentile of
the distances between configurations
that are crisscrossing
okay so so here are some results we got
um so we use Pasha in this case for
neural architecture search meaning we
would need to decide what layers to use
in a convolution in your network and how
to wire them so there are various
options like convolutional layers with
different kernel sizes different pooling
layers skip connections and so on and
run it for three image data sets either
10 100 and imagenet
and um so this table is a bit big so
just pay attention to the the Asha one
this one here which is
basically successive halving it's an
asynchronous version of that which would
work a little bit better if you run in
parallel and the partial one obviously
um so what we need to pay attention to
is the accuracy so what we would like to
see here is that Pasha basically Works
equally well to martial successive
halfing right because we we want to go
faster but not sacrifice any accuracy
and this is what we see sometimes we're
a bit worse sometimes we're a bit better
and the other interesting part is the
speed up Factor so how much faster are
we compared to success of farthing and
here we would see that it's two times
three times faster
so that's great however there are also
limitations to partial so I don't want
to claim it's working all the time right
and obviously it only works in cases
well where you have a lot of budget so
if you just have very few epochs then
yeah Pasha can't stop earlier right
so for that reason we created this
artificial experiment where we decreased
the number of epochs that we from 200
which we had on the previous slide to
and just check how well it's doing in
that case and what we see while it's
still a bit faster it's not as fast
anymore as before
and obviously this setting the budget in
this case was set to number of epochs
but you can choose freely right you
could also use the number of iterations
you take maybe one you know budget level
is just 50 iteration steps or whatever
right and then you can artificially blow
up
um your budget again
great
um so as I promised I would also show
you how to use it in practice so this is
the first time where we come to this
point so we integrated Pasha into
scientune
um probably no one of you have ever
heard about sign tune but scientune is
an open source hyper permit optimization
Library which has a lot of algorithms
including all the ones we talk about in
this talk it has a couple of other nice
features for example it
um as all these algorithms in their
asynchronous and parallel way which
means in practice you can run any
algorithm in parallel on multiple
machines
um and if you're not only caring about
increasing accuracy but you also want to
do some constrained and multi-objective
optimization for example you want to
maximize accuracy but also minimize
inference time this is also something
you could do with that um Library
and whilst
since we're working on that and we are
AWS it's also well integrated into this
entire AWS uh in the whole AWS products
like for example sagemaker so you would
not need to write any code here it would
just work out of the box so as mentioned
it's open source it's on GitHub the link
is below there if you want to check it
out
so how to use partial or assign you it's
relatively simple so you first of all
would create this partial object right
where you pass the search space which is
called your config space and then you
would Define something like I want to
maximize accuracy and then your tuner
would basically kick off the training
process what you would pass here is your
training script which would give the
hyper parameters training model and then
at the end report back the performance
you got and then you can Define how for
how long to work with it and how many
workers are running in parallel and and
that's it um that would basically do
everything you need
okay let's come to to the the the next
interesting use case I think which is
re-tuning hyper parameters over and over
again
um so the next algorithm Rush um is
based on this entire idea of doing
transfer learning for hyper parameter
optimization
um I'm think it's not super well known
that idea but so the idea here is that
we Define and if a data set I is similar
to a data set J then also the response
functions are similar meaning in
practice they behave similar in this
hyper parameter space so if a hyper
parameter configuration is great on data
set I it will also be a great one for J
um yeah I mean figuring that out is hard
just based on the raw data um still what
we could do is learn from this kind of
information and to make it a bit more
visual what we see here are basically
response functions plotted
for um two hyper parameters of an svm
with an RBF kernel each plot represents
one data set basically so we we have
here response functions for a couple of
data sets and just I mean you don't need
to really understand just look at them
and you will see that some of them have
a similar shape meaning that they are
similar in the hyper parameter
space and that kind of indicates that if
you would have the knowledge of one of
them that would be very helpful if you
would solve the HBO problem for the
other one
and this is not limited to you know you
know hyper parameters for an svm
um this is the same as for um in
algorithm selection but also in neural
architecture search so for example here
we have and I guess not super surprising
we we trained I think 200 different
convolutional convolutional neural
network architectures on c410 and 100
and just created a scatter plot and you
see they are highly correlated
while I guess for Siva 10 100 that's not
super surprising we did this for a
couple of other data sets as well and
even though they are not super related I
mean on the first um look they did the
the performance of architectures are
still kind of related so there's useful
information there and
um yeah coming from here now to rush so
the premise in Rush is that we Now
default some good
default settings like in this set we
call I
um I'm going to talk later about how to
get that
and given this set I what rush does it's
basically changing so sex success of
halfing with a very simple rule we're
not only dropping configurations that
um you know the worst 50 but we're also
dropping all the configurations which
are not doing as well as configurations
in eye
so in case of a positive transfer with
positive transfer what I mean with this
is that if the data set we're currently
optimizing for is similar to
or where the configurations and I do
well on the data set we're currently
optimizing for then Rush will basically
be super fast because what it would do
is many configurations will be
immediately stopped
in the case of negative transfer this is
like the worst case scenario where
basically the configurations that I are
useless
then what rush would do it would fall
back to success of farthing so it would
not give you a speed up but the
important thing here is that it would
also not fail so you would still have
some guarantees that it works
um so we we come to our visualization
again
so it looks similar in the beginning the
difference is now the blue
um Circle this is basically our
configuration from the set I again we
would
um evaluate them rank them this is the
positive transfer case so our
said I is a good one so our blue circle
gets a good ranking
and what we wouldn't now do is drop the
50 which are the black circles as before
but We additionally also dropped the
gray ones according to the new rule
because they are not as good as the blue
one
and then we will just keep going uh and
again we would drop the other one and
we're done so as you see we drop way
more configurations now in the positive
transfer case
now we can also have a look at the
negative transverse so in this case the
blue configuration isn't doing that well
in this case what's basically done is
it's dropped immediately
um
and so everything else that's now coming
should be very familiar to you because
it's effectively just doing success of
halfing
um so in this case we are not saving
anything but we would still find
Solutions which are yeah equally good as
in success evolving obviously
um yeah let's come back to our running
example
um so
yeah I've now added Rush here compared
to successive halving this is the case
where we
um assume a positive transfer meaning
um yeah as I said in the the first
example and what we would see here is
that since Russia is dropping many
configurations uh we reduce the number
of epochs significantly it's now yeah
more than
two times fewer epochs than in success
of halfing and so we bring down the cost
to less than 200 dollars
um
so what what I didn't talk about so far
is how do we get this initial set of
configurations on and that really
depends on what experience you have with
the algorithm you want to use
so in many algorithms there are default
settings so you could just use the
default setting as you said I
um if you're familiar with the algorithm
you you're using on the data set and
you've tried it on some other data sets
as I showed you
um in the intrinsic learning for HBO you
could just use the best configurations
from the other data sets and put them in
I
and I think what many people are doing
is they just have the same data set
which is changing over time
and in that case what you could simply
do is you just choose the best
configurations you had on the very same
data set
um in previous update runs so it's kind
of similar to the one with the other
tasks but the difference being that the
data is basically
yeah kind of similar I mean there might
be some shifts in distribution but yeah
so the the last part is more this
continue learning aspect what the other
ones are independent task is solve is
solving
and speaking of continue learning so no
wrong transition uh we we still have
some experiments here so these are the
empirical results for the scenario where
we are doing
um this re tuning and so we took 40
different data sets and basically
retuned with rush and compared it
against Bayesian optimization and
successive halving
so these plots are a bit more
complicated so I guess and also very
tiny um so I would need to explain
um so in each plot we basically have
different bins or cells and the number
within the cell and the color indicate
how many data sets fall into that
category
okay and on the x-axis what we have is
basically here at zero I'm not sure one
can read that that means that there's no
difference between Russia and successive
laughing so they're doing equally well
if it's to the right side that means
Russia it's doing better if it's the
left side successive halving is doing
better and similarly we have the same
thing on the y-axis but this is with
respect to time
so I don't know whether one can see it
but the zero is somewhere up there
and Haya means Russia's doing better so
what we see in most of these data sets
for this Rich tuning scenario Russia is
basically giving us
um
yeah the same accuracy as successive
puffing but it's two or three times
faster
and as I mentioned Bayesian optimization
can be super competitive if you spend
enough on budget so this is what we're
seeing here some data sets are very far
to the left right so these are cases
where we have just sufficient tuning
budget so this will give you better
Solutions in that case but we see that
most of these data sets are somewhere in
this region where you maybe are the same
or you you're one percent better
and now just check the the the the
numbers on the y-axis right so Russia's
like 30 40 50 times faster and that's
that's the massive difference in time
and money right and this is what I
mentioned earlier you would need to
think about whether you really need the
best cyber parameters and that yeah
always depends on how much budget you
spend and your data set as well
um okay great so as I mentioned this
this would basically work create in this
continue learning setting
um
what
ah
currently I'm done can I wrap up quickly
uh so we we added Russia also to to sign
tune but we also added it to Renata
that's some cool open source Library we
are currently working in so if you have
this continue learning setup this would
be a great tool
um I can't go into details but basically
you just need to pie touch module easy
data access
and then you basically just execute one
function and you indicate you would want
to use rush and
it will basically do the update for you
um
concluding
either my time is wrong or he is time is
wrong
but we
um I hope I gave you some introduction
to hyper permit optimization some basic
techniques we have seen how Mighty
Fidelity optimization
um Can can speed up things significantly
I gave a short intro to transfer
learning for HBO which is actually a
pretty cool topic and they're way more
interesting algorithms and yeah I try to
to to give you some some point as to how
to use it in practice thanks a lot for
your attention so I have pointers to the
papers here
um for the partial and Rush algorithm
Pasha was just recently um accepted at
iClear and also pointers to the library
so if you check out the repo please
leave a stop we appreciate that a lot
okay any questions
[Applause]
thank you Martin
thank you for the interesting
presentation I said there are quite a
few questions already we'll try to
answer as much as we can but if not
please know that marketing will be
around and you can ask him you can talk
to him personally afterwards
um sorry Martin also for hearing you up
but this schedule is tight so yeah the
first question is from Benedict and he
says from your point of view when would
you put trying out parameters over
reasoning on parameter values based on
their meaning
I'm sorry can you so I mean I guess the
question means uh when it's better to
try out parameters instead of reasoning
a bit about the meaning of the each
parameter and say maybe it's better to
use a different value here and not there
ah okay I mean this this is hot
this is tricky I mean also you're
getting back to the point that this
becomes a manual process sure you have
some control by setting the search Space
by saying for this type of parameter I
want it between this in this range you
could say I want to have it on a log
scale for example learning right you
would do it on a log scale right but in
a way we don't really want to do it
manually I guess
um so I don't know I mean I'm not a big
fan of doing a manual because I'm a lazy
person but
I guess if you have some domain
knowledge uh yeah maybe maybe
thank you another question is when using
rush if your default settings are fairly
good do you not run the danger of
getting stuck in the local Optimum in
which you started
um
I mean there are problems with Russia I
would not see the problem that we're
getting stuck in Optimum because
assuming our modifidality scores are
very good correlated with the final
performance a better configuration would
still do better than the I said and I
right the problem will be if these
intermediate scores are not highly
correlated with tn1 like in the extreme
case they are anti-correlated so you
would basically drop all the
configurations which actually do good if
you would train them under completion
but that's a problem with all these
multi-fidelity methods because they
assume that there is some stronger
correlation between
early performances and uh late
performance
and next question is how would you
handle unstable configurations that
perform extremely well one out of five
times how do you include stability into
the HBO interesting question
um I I would argue we don't want those
configurations in the first place but
obviously it can happen that we pick one
and then we retrain and it's not working
anymore
if that's really the case it's extremely
tricky and we would need to do something
like cross validation which becomes even
more expensive but in practice I yeah I
mean at least with the neural networks
I've worked with they are rather stable
to be fair
and our question is evaluation is done
on test data what can we do to take into
account performance on training data to
be close to Performance and test data to
avoid overfitting
um so
two new hyper parameters
[Music]
no I mean I guess here the the you
test data needs to be representative
right you're basically checking with on
the test date or the validation data
generalization
but usually you would still always
perform better on tests just by
definition
um
I I'm not sure that that's where the
question is hinting to upon
things regarding multi-fidelity how do I
know if results in lower fidelities are
a good proxy for the performance in the
final fidelity
good question uh you don't uh you would
hope so that that's the Assumption we
make in these algorithms so if you want
to be certain about that just try it
with few configurations obviously if you
ran before for example a random search
or grid search and you you just track
the entire learning curve you could
check for yourself
thanks and our question is why do you
drop 50 percent of runs and double the
ebooks are in those hyper parameters as
well I mean actually there are some they
are they are and in practice even though
the name is successive offing people do
not have but they throw away two thirds
so this is like the default hyper
parameter but
I know it's confusing
but I didn't want to confuse you with
that detail so um yes it's a hyper hyper
parameter you can set it however you
want you can make it more aggressive
like using one third or even more but
yeah I mean we don't want to get into
hyper parameter optimization of hyper
optimization methods so I hope not at
least Inception
um another question it's actually quite
useful it's will you share your slides
yeah I saw in the previous talks that
people are doing that and I didn't
prepare that on one slide but I should
do that I'm not sure how to communicate
the
the link oh
I guess we can talk later maybe we can
put it on Discord
yeah maybe yeah
um okay and our question is from Flavio
what do you think of using mixed
Precision instead of full Precision for
hyper parameter optimization to speed up
the search and lower the training costs
what
makes precision
I'm not sure what it refers to I know
that some people do it with the
parameters of a neural network but I
guess for hyper parameter doesn't it
really makes sense
I mean maybe I'm misunderstanding the
question maybe Flavio you can come by
later and explain directly to Martin
yeah yeah
and our question is what
okay when would you use rash or Pasha
when are they more beneficial
um I mean in Russia you kind of need
this extra information of I right so if
you don't have that you would not use it
um and I think Russia is also more
aggressive than partial so meaning it
it's cheaper but might also give lesser
um good hyper parameters so this this
again is the question of algorithm
selection on hyper parameter
optimization algorithm so yeah it's
tricky uh you would need to play a
little bit around that
um
yeah I don't have a super definite
answer for that
okay thank you Martin again from the
club
[Applause]